hey what's up guys my name is a cello
and a lot um dare is closing in there's
like a day and a half left till it
starts bit more than that actually but
um yeah so I just wanted to make an
update video to tell you guys what's
going to be happening because um you
know the other video asked you guys what
platform you're you want to be the
stream on and like everyone said twitch
so I actually sent a revised contract
machinima and they've signed it so in
other words will be streaming on twitch
and specifically will be streaming on
twitch.tv fourth pitcher know ok so the
link to that stream is in the
description I have streamed there before
like before I was dreaming on youtube so
like january two thousand twelve so yeah
like over a year ago but um yeah so that
channel is that Twitter TV channel is a
channel that will be um posting my
stream bottom deaf and yeah so basically
you guys can go there right now and hit
the follow button if you want to be
notified when I start streaming but um
the better way actually to be honest is
to follow me on twitter because i'll be
tweeting stuff throughout the throughout
the streaming especially when i start
and stop streaming like the first place
to know will be twitter i'll also post
like a video on youtube saying that i'm
going to be streaming and sort of that
when love them dead bell start but again
you know twitter twitter is going to be
the best a twitter com pulse at Ruggiano
again linked being is in the description
that um that's probably gonna be one of
the best ways to actually know if i'm
streaming a lot of another again you can
actually watch which the TV even on your
phone like I assume that have an app for
Android but they definitely go on for
iOS so ipad and iphone and I guess ipod
touch as well um so you guys can
download that and even if you're not a
[ __ ] even if you don't have access to a
computer you can still um you can still
chained to the stream and see what's
going on and the other thing is yeah i
mean i'll be streaming the entire thing
so that'll be like like i'm actually
i've i've actually um what i've done
over the past week pretty much as i've
just got all of my university Simon's
out of the way I've actually had today
just thursday off because it's Anzac Day
in Australia which which is a public
holiday and yeah so I didn't have you
need uni today so instead i just spent
pretty much the whole day finishing my
assignments so that I would have the
weekend clear so in other words last
year last time in August you might
recall that I actually had to pretty
much rush the developing a lot because
um because I had school work to do but
this time I shouldn't have to have that
problem unless something comes up
tomorrow which I hope it won't but um
yeah so it should be it should be a good
time anyway and I should be able to
really um spend a bit more time this
time around but yeah so twitch.tv for
such a journal is there anything else i
want to say i don't think so twitch.tv
currently has two different layouts as
soon as you go to my channel on twitter
TV you'll actually like to see like a
banner up up the top which has welcome
to the new channel page and then it's
called like keepers default or go back
to the old one you guys can go back to
the old one if you want or you can keep
it as well doesn't matter but um it's
completely up to you I'm not sure I
haven't decided which one looks better
there but I'm pretty good i'm looking at
them right now but um yeah regardless
that's um that's just a new development
that pushes and making but um the cool
thing about twitches that you guys can
go to that channel page and whenever i'm
streaming you'll actually see me we like
streaming so it's not like on YouTube
where you have to follow a specific link
or something right after featured on my
channel like on twitch if i'll be
streaming if i am live it'll be on that
page so yeah other than that guys i'm
probably actually going to start the
live stream around 1230pm australian
eastern standard time on 27th of april
2013 so it actually pretty much says
that in the title of the stream but um
that's where I want to start streaming
it off so you guys there that so that's
half an hour before life starts just
like to get everything in order save the
streams working correctly and yeah and
yet ready for let him do anyway I'm sort
of trailing on this video just cuz I
pretty much having I having a capital
conversation with you with you bros but
um yeah so it should be good the other
thing I wanted to say is everyone who
plans on coming to the stream hit the
like button on this video just so that I
can see like what the numbers are
roughly going to be like and yeah we
should have fun so I'll see you guys
there goodbye